Vsauce!
Kevin here.
In the U.S. you may be able to order Cinnabon
balls filled with frosting but Taco Bell in
Guatemala offers the Chocodilla.
A dessert quesadilla filled with chocolate.
And if you want a taco in India you can find
that at Domino's.
The McDonald's menu in India features drastically
different items because the people of India
have a largely vegetarian diet.
So they have the Veg McMuffin instead of the
Egg McMuffin and rather than a traditional
Big Mac there's the Chicken Maharaja Mac.
There's also the McAloo Tiki which is a fried
potato and pea patty in a bun.
While KFC India features a deep-fried cheese
patty called the Paneer Zinger.
As well as chicken and veggie rice bowls.
KFC in China serves spins on the classics
ranging from Golden Curry pork chop rice to
chicken sandwiches topped with prawns.
Also the website features fun translations
like bacon chicken oats fort and suck that
chicken flavor.
Yeah, I'll have the nine suck that chicken
flavor!
McDonald's in China as part of their manly
man campaign offered a mashed potato burger.
And instead of french fries you can get corn
and instead of an apple pie you can get taro
pie.
Now let's take a quick look at Pizza Hut pizza
crust stuffed with things.
Also Singapore had a pizza on top of a pizza
and for dessert Thailand has the chocolate
almond pizza.
Pizza Hut and Domino's in Japan offers several
types of pizza with mayonnaise.
Japanese mayonnaise is thinner and sweeter
than American and made with apple and malt
vinegar and egg yolks instead of whole eggs.
Japanese KFC not only has soy sauce flavored
rice balls and deep-fried soup fritters but
a sweet and spicy soy sauce chicken sandwich.
The Japanese McDonald's menu piles huge chunks
of avocado on several burgers.
Another burger has meat sauce that looks like
this and they also have a burger made with
shrimp.
McDonald's in Italy serves creamy stars that
are filled with cheese and they also have
calzones.
Apparently there you can also just get a block
of parmesan cheese.
While Spain offers up a nice cup of McDonald's
gazpacho and Arabic countries feature the
McArabia chicken - which is folded in Arabic
bread.
KFC Arabia has a chicken poppers sandwich
which has chicken and deep fried cheese-stuffed
jalapeño poppers on bread.
Germans burger can be very long as witnessed
by their Burger King's x-tra long chili cheese
burger and x-tra long spring bbq burger.
They also have chicken nugget burgers.
And a waffle covered in chocolate for dessert.
Here's a quick look at some promotional items
from around the world.
Rolled cheeseburgers.
Dark Vader Burger.
Popcorn chicken Nachos and Nacho chicken sandwich.
Donut pizza that features a hollow center
and pizza-sized burger.
And while here in the US we've had things
like Friendly's Grilled Cheese Burger Melt
or the Bacon Insider withbacon inside the
burger.
They don't compare to Japan's 10 patty titan
burger served with a jumbo bucket of fries.
Which for Lotteria and their tower burger
and shrimp burger is actually no big deal...
And as always - thanks for watching.